hello everyone and welcome to round
three of the video World rapid
Championship 2022 we have a very very
exciting game and it's a very
complicated game between two times
Russian championshipsky who defeated
Andrew tang and Arena jumab at face
magnets in round three and as we've been
covering magnus's games you know who
Magnus faced it's a really brutal game
uh and uh well even against such a
strong opponent Magnus goes for uh for
an offbeat opening that you you'd expect
him to use in sort of maybe a Blitz game
but uh here he uses it in in World rapid
championships so let's check it out and
see what happens uh if again with the
white pieces opens with D4 Magnus goes
for G6 we have E4 and now D6 we have
Knight the C3 Bishop to G7 Knight to F3
and A6 this is something that Magnus um
uses quite a lot we have a for now uh
and pawn to B6 we have Bishop to C4 and
now even Pawn to E6 so a lot of pawn
moves but if it works uh it just works
we have castles Bay of Guinea and the
Knight to E7 uh we have Rook the E1 and
Knight the D7 now if you look at this uh
it really looks like uh something a
child would do just because it looks
nice but that's how how the theory goes
Bishop to F4 and now Bishop to B7 by
Magnus Queen D2 uh going for that Bishop
to H6 and now even H6 which means uh
that Magnus is not Castle in kingside uh
anytime soon as the H6 Pawn would hang
and there is a game where H3 was played
but here we have Rook 8 to D1 by Evgeni
and it is now as of move 11 that we have
a completely new game so how can Magnus
continue this he plays G5 and okay
Bishop goes back to G3 we have Knight to
G6 now controlling some very nice
squares here uh and pawn to H3 uh also
very interesting is for example E5 if
Magnus advances the pawn to D5 then
Bishop to D3 and uh well you it's uh
it's definitely quite a position that
Knight and G6 will be captured and if
black can survive this uh well good for
him but if again he trusts Magnus he
plays Spawn to H3 with castles by Magnus
now castling is an option and now Knight
to H2 remanuary the Knight to F1 we have
King the H7 and now Knight to F1 Knight
to F6 uh and now Queen to E2
uh we have Queen to D7 Magnus develops
the queen connects the Rooks and now
Pawn to E5 also maybe before Pawn to E5
you could consider Bishop to D3 it's
always very annoying uh having your king
and the same diagonal as the bishop but
evgeny goes for the immediate E5 and it
makes sense since the queen is on D7 so
it seems like you really shouldn't open
up the D file but that's exactly what
Magnus does and this is where things get
really interesting the captures on E5 D
captures an E5 attacking magnus's Knight
and the Queen and now not Knights the D5
blocking but Queen to C6 Magnus
threatens Checkmate on G2 so of course
you have to stop this Knight to E3 and
now comes Knight to D7 and the position
is uh very complicated it seems that the
Magnus pulled off this offbeat opening
and that he's completely out of the
woods maybe even starting to grab some
initiative however uh that also could
not be further from the truth uh feel
free to pause the video and try to find
well dare I say it a already a winning
move for evgeny uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on being able to
visualize a lot of squares and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Bishop to B5 beautiful move by
evgeny he played it and now Magnus is in
trouble because the queen will not be
able to remain on C6 the pawn will cover
C6 this Pawn covers D6 and The Rook is
coming to the D7 square and the seventh
rank so you have to capture the the
bishop otherwise you just lose material
eight characters eight captures with
Queen to C5 and now Rook captures on D7
completely shattering all of magnus's
ideas and here Magnus goes for Bishop
captures on E5 he grabs that pawn queen
to C4 uh preparing something very
special Bishop to C8 trying to kick away
The Rook from the D7 square and here we
have Queen captures and c5b captures and
now the absolute most precise way to
play this and to take advantage of the
pause the video moment that you guys
solved is Rook captures on C7 and then
after Bishop capture Bishop captures you
will enjoy a beautiful past beep on for
example Bishop Bishop B7 B6 and a very
nice very nice position for white
however Bishop captures an E5 was played
it's sort of the same idea only it
allows Magnus to improve his pieces a
bit more Bishop captures on D7 with
Bishop captures on C7 and now comes
Knight to F4 uh here Rook F the C8 is uh
at the absolute best weight to defend
for example Rook F to C8 attacks the
bishop and now if you play B6 Rook just
capture C7 you do not want to allow
white to have this bishop Pawn setup so
Bishop to D6 and now Rook a 7 to B7 will
keep an eye on the B Pawn but Magnus
went for Knight to F4 right away and now
comes Knight the C4 and here uh just to
show you how how beautiful the position
is uh evgeny could have won with Rook to
D1 look at this bishop it has no squares
you cannot defend it uh the only thing
you can do is is uh well you could block
with knights to D5 which just gives up
more material a knight capture C
captures Rook captures again the bishop
is attacked you have to go to C8 or
after Rook to D1 you will have to go
Bishop to C8 right away and now uh
Black's position is just terrible the
Rooks are disconnected the bishop is on
a terrible square and once this Pawn
starts marching forward uh there will be
no uh stopping that but uh in the game
Knight the C4 was played by evgeny and
this allows again Magnus to bounce back
into the gate Knight to D5 and here we
have Knight captures and D5 with Knight
the E5 white is still putting some
pressure but even Guinea uh dropped
really really low on the clock here he
was down to Sun 20 seconds and Magnus
still had some two more minutes on the
clock so here e captures on B5 Knight
the B6 attacks The Rook attacks the uh
the bishop and here uh probably what
you're getting was expecting is for
Magnus just to give back the exchange
pick up the pawn here and then after
Knight captures Rook captures you you
play this and okay not not much to be
done here equal material should be a
draw but Magnus said nope he wants to
play this for a win now he plays Rook 8
to E8 and now we have Rook character 78
Bishop capture 78 of course not Rook you
have to save the bishop and now Bishop
to D6 attacks The Rook in the C5 Pawn
also the D5 Pawn is hanging so you don't
have time uh for of uh to save
everything Rook to G8 and now Knight
captures on D5 threatening Knight to F6
with check so Rook the G6 also you
that's a very nice way of reintroducing
The Rook into the game and the shot
captures on C5 so evgeny is down the
exchange but uh he does have some extra
pawns here even after Bishop captures on
B5 he still has two connected uh pawns
on the on the queen side with C3 uh Rook
to A6 by Magnus and now Pawn to B4 and
now once the bishop comes to D4 there is
no way you are ever touching any of
these pawns as they are on dark squares
you have a light Square Bishop so yeah
evgeny is of course very confident that
he will be able to draw this game but
Magnus will try he cannot lose this Pawn
to F5 Knight the C7 now attacks the rook
and the bishop and The Rook the A1 check
Magnus of course not interested in
trading the bishop King H2 we have
Bishop the C4 and this bishop is now
beautiful here preventing either Pawn
from moving forward and if again it
would all very much love to remove that
Bishop from there so 98 coming to D6
King to G6 and now Knight to D6 with
Bishop to D3 uh and here uh Bishop to D4
is the move you you you kind of want to
play and it's it's a safe move but again
it goes upon to B5 sorry uh Pawn to B5
uh would be the safe mode to play here
but if Guinea plays Bishop to D4 and
this just allows Magnus to mobilize his
pieces to perfect squares Rook to B1 now
prevents any pushes as both the bishop
and the row control the B5 square and if
you push C4 then the B4 Pawn hangs so
here Bishop to E5 again he just now has
the play moves to see what happens
Magnus pushes F4 with Bishop to D4 now
H4 and here you have to play F3 or
something that does not give Magnus a
winning idea but if Guinea did exactly
that he played Bishop to E5 and now Rook
to B2 goes after the F2 pawn and once
again you have to play Bishop to D4 to
defend it and even then your possession
will be hard to defend but he played
King to G1 and this allows Magnus to go
for the win as he has a very very
peculiar idea in mind so feel free to
pause the video and to win the game for
Magnus now while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
to E2 uh the idea of course is that the
bishop as only square is the D4 square
or the H square but if you play or
Bishop to h8 you are a very special
player so Bishop to D4 has to be played
and then it is possible to continue
pushing with the G4 and what does this
mean why is this so strong well look at
this bishop to D4 G for now you have to
capture or you don't uh doesn't really
matter or or it doesn't really change
anything you've gain it captured here
and after King to H2 now Magnus threw in
a beautiful G3 with check which means
that the F3 Pawn is now uh coming
forward and it doesn't matter what you
do if King to G1 uh then of course the
H2 square is covered a rook D1 will be
Checkmate so you have to capture or you
go to H3 it doesn't really matter then
the spawn promotes or you have to give
up the bishop so in the game after this
check F characters and G3 was played and
now of course the only winning move but
one is all Magnus needs F3 and now there
is no stopping a rook captures on on G2
G4 was played Rook captures on G2 with
check King H3 and Magnus finishes with a
very nice Ponte F2 trying to give up The
Rook for uh getting the queen into the
game with Tempo but it was also in this
position on move 50 that evgenito
machenski resigned to the game after
playing a beautiful game he completely
uh nullified magnus's attempt to go for
the for the tricky robosh and he
completely outplayed Him special with
that Bishop a bishop to B5 move but it
just wasn't enough at some point he
started spending too much time he gave
Magnus one chance to avoid the draw
Magnus took it and the Magnus is now on
three out of three alongside Arjun
irrigation and Vladimir fedosev so we'll
see who Magnus faces in round four uh
but yeah very very very very nicely done
by Magnus getting out of this and you
know keeping his cool and then out
playing such a such a strong two-time
Russian champion
uh yeah of course like I said if King
captures an F1 Queen and if you don't uh
there's really not all that much you can
play I mean you could play Bishop
captures and then white is just down a
full Rook uh so yeah after F2 you're
getting resigned and another victory for
Magnus Carlsen who now uh Returns the
three and we're not returns to who now
gets three out of three uh so that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh I would
like to thank Ricky black Lars Oliver
groundhapper uh Jeff Graves David Rice
Oxley and David Kimura for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
which are now both from the rapid World
Championship uh and uh you know uh I I I
I'm gonna continue covering it until it
finishes uh so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day